a coders I'm Cody Seibert and welcome to
another tutorial where I'm going to show
you how to build a calculator app using
view GS so to start off let's just go
ahead and show you what we're building
so I'm just gonna load up the Mac
calculator which has kind of a grid
guess this is a calf or by five grid
that has buttons he had different
operands and operators and of course you
have a display section up here so that's
what we're gonna try to emulate and I
don't know if it's gonna work 100% as
this app does but we're gonna try to get
close so moving on I'm kind of going to
skip the set up I basically use vcli to
set up this project here and what we're
gonna do is just kind of modify what's
already there to build out our
calculator app so to start off let's go
into the app table view file let's just
go ahead and clean some of this up so
that we only display our calculator so
I'm gonna get rid of us image
and I'm also going to get rid of this
hello world but instead of just deleting
it I'm going to go ahead and rename it
to calculator
then anywhere I'm importing it just
change out the calculator
so I'll save that that's going to crash
because obviously we haven't created the
calculator component so if I go back to
my components folder I'm just going to
rename hello world to calculator
a head and gut basically everything we
have so we can start fresh and just to
verify that this is working I'll leave a
little hello world message in here and
say that
go ahead and gut the Stiles gut the
source
and we are good to go at this point
we don't need to touch any of the other
files that I that I'm aware of so let's
go ahead and talk about what we need to
do we go back and look at that
calculator it has a kind of a grid
structure so I'm thinking about using
CSS grid to kind of replicate that so
let's go up here let's remove that and
let's just call this calculator
inside our Styles I'm going to define a
new calculator class
we can use CSS grid so I'm gonna say
grid template columns I'm gonna say
there's gonna be four columns that I'm
going to repeat them with equal
right so this is a way to do like
percentages so each one it has the same
equal percentage of each other
for the rose this will kind of make
sense in a second when we visualize it
for the Rose I'm just going to give it a
grid Otto rose
put some spacing automatically between
all of our rows so each one should at
least be 50 and height I'm gonna save
this what this is going to do is
basically any child element of our
calculator component is going to be put
into eight or by infinity grid
that I'll to say span hello
is that a couple times
in fact I think it might need that he
divs let's see
in fact I think I forgot to say display
is bread
okay so definitely don't forget that
line 19 display grid that tells the
component that it needs to be a grid a
CSS grid so if you notice here as I keep
pasting new components we're getting a
four column by infinite amount of rows
grid so that's kind of a step in the
right direction and what do we need for
our calculator well first of all we
needed a display let me say class
display
and I'll just type in some random number
here
and what we need to do is we need to
make this display span the entire top
four columns so if we go down at the
bottom of the style and say display
we can specify how many columns that
display should take up so I could say
grid column I want to start at column 1
and I want it to in after column 4 so if
I save this that displays will take up
the entire first row and to kind of
demonstrate that a little bit better I'm
gonna say make it red so we can
visualize right
and then let's just go ahead and make
the font a little bit larger for all
these so I'm going to say font size of
40 pixels just to make it a little bit
easier to read so at this point we can
start implementing the rest so let's
look and see what we need we need a row
that has AC plus minus percent and a
divide icon so here I'll just get rid of
this
and I'll say we're do plus minus
I think was percent then we have a
divided it was pasted in here so if I
say that we kind of have our first row
ready to go and now for the second row
seven eight nine times I do the same
thing seven eight
and then I'll just put an X for x so
save that let's just go ahead and
continue four five six -
four five six
- never need
or three
one two three I believe one two
three plus
and finally we have a zero dot and
equals so I'll just do that
zero dot so one thing we'll notice is
that the zero I forgot to add a plus so
let me just do that but we need to zero
that take up two columns right so how do
we do that before we use that grid
- column
last so what we can do here is just say
are on the zero
I'm gonna say classes you row and then
down in the style I'm going to say zero
is a grid column of one comma or 1/3
which will give it two columns in this
hmm
and now since all of these are kind of
like buttons let's just go ahead and
give it a class button for all these
obviously I could just give them buttons
I'm just to keep it simple though I'm
just going to give it to class equals
button
go ahead and fix that in zero
go down here and I'll make a new button
style so be in background color
is equal to NRT for now
order one pixel solid
right so we're making a little bit of
progress so going back to the calculator
notice that this whole row here or
column I mean as kind of like an orange
text or the or orange color in the
background
so what I'm going to do here is define a
new class called operator
background color orange and then a text
color of white
and then for emi operators so that
includes divide I'm going to give it a
class operator x minus plus and equals
I'll save that and now we have the
correct coloring for these operators
let's just go back one more time and
look to see if we're missing anything
yeah so at this point it seems pretty
good I mean we could probably spend
hours just messing with the styles to
make sure it looks good
so now that we have a decent layout
going and of course let's just get rid
of this red make that something else
a better border I'm still being kind of
nitpicky here the borders a little
there we go
of course if you don't want the the
columns that be so large what you could
do is just set a width to our calculator
I'll give it a with like 400 pixels
and then a margin:0 auto to make it
centered here
so our calculator is looking a little
bit more like this calculator here I'm
not gonna spend too much time making it
look exactly as is mmm
like I don't need to text the line this
right or whatnot but anyway the next fun
steps is we need to declare the logic in
the bindings to our different buttons
and display
the first thing I see here is we could
probably abstract this into a view data
property here so let's go to our view
component and declare a data function
which returns something that has a
display or a current set equal to an
empty string and then up here I'm going
to just interpolate that here and say
current so it's going to render whatever
the current data value is so for
instance if I say 1 2 3 that's going to
render out 1 2 3 or if I type hello
world that's going to type out the
string but for now we're going to keep
that blank and then we're just going to
fall back on a 0 if it's not defined and
then we can kind of just go through
these buttons and one by one add
whatever functionality we need to it so
to start off let's just do a click call
back on the Clear button and we're going
to call a function called clear
and to define functions on your view
component and notice that this is a view
component all you need to do is add a
methods attribute and then define the
method that you want so I'm going to say
clear as a method and what it's going to
do it's going to reset current back to
the empty string here so if we were to
have something typed in there and we
clicked on the see notice that it goes
back to zero
so moving right along
try to implement the next method which
is sine so again I'm just going to add a
click listener to this and call a sine
method
and then I'm going to go and implement
that sign method here so what do we want
to do in the user clicks plus or minus
basically we just want to append a minus
in front of here if it doesn't already
exist or if it doesn't exist we just go
ahead and remove it so one way to do
that is we could just say this dot
current is equal to this current and dot
carrot
is going to be ternary operator where we
just check if the first character is
equal to a minus and we're going to
return that string without that first
character otherwise we're going to
return that string with a minus sign
appended to it
so now if we were to go and type in
this just goes and that's probably
something we should try to fix but um if
we assume that way I should have a
number here like one two three four
oops put on the wrong thing so one two
three four if I say that notice that the
plus or minus is now adding to it now oh
cool so we might have to come back and
just change that up a little bit I think
for now we can move along to the
percentage so let me add a new called
new one called oh sorry let me add a new
click call back called percent
and down here to the methods same idea
we're just going to add a callback
function and what we're gonna do here is
basically just divide whatever number it
is by a hundred so this current is equal
to the string of ours float this dot
current divided by 100
all right so just take the current
string value make it a float divide it
by 100 and then cast it back to a string
here so to kind of show that lets just
make current equal to like 600
then if I click on that percentage
notice that it becomes six
it should become zero point or 0.06 okay
so that is working fine awesome at this
point you should kind of see how easy it
is to like write out your functionality
your calculator has a particular state
and we're modifying the state as we
click the different methods here
let's move along to the
different numbers at this point I think
we'll leave the operators for once we
have the numbers implemented so the
implement the numbers basically we need
to think what do we need to do every
time we click on one of these we just
need to append to the end of this string
right so that should be pretty
straightforward let's make a method
called append
and that's going to take a number as an
argument and what we're going to do is
we're going to say this dot current is
equal to this current plus number
and in fact I don't like doing plus here
because we're kind of doing string
concatenation so I'm going to do this
dot current
and candidated with number so it's more
explicit that we're just joining two
strings together
can actually use this method we just
created if we go up to here and for any
time we have a number
I'm just going to go ahead and use that
click callback must a at click is equal
to a pinned
then for each one just go ahead and put
in the string that we want to append so
seven eight nine four five six
one two
I'd say that
and I forgot to do 0 so let me just go
and add 0 here
let's see so does this work
seems like it so let's just go ahead and
add everything 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 at zero
works fine
not sure if that's proper but we won't
worry about that right now
all right so moving along last thing we
have for the operands is this dot
just doing another click call back and
call it dot
it's going to call a function
dot and let's of course make sure we did
find a function down here called dot
what we're going to do is very similar
to a pinned but we only want to append
the dot if it doesn't already exist so
I'm gonna say this dot current if sorry
if this dot current about index of the
dot is not equal to negative one
to upend it in fact I'm just going to
say make sure that the dot doesn't exist
and if it doesn't exist
we can just say this not append and then
append the dot
that's basically just gonna call this
method here with the period just let me
save this type in some numbers type in a
dot click some more numbers try dotting
again and notice that it doesn't append
it anymore
alright we're making some really good
progress now to the more difficult part
of building a calculator app which is
the operators so for each of these
operators we want to call a different
kind of click call back
for this one I'm gonna say divide four
times I'm just gonna say times
-
and then for this one
so for those four operators just go
ahead and declare those four methods so
divided
times
-
and then we have plus I think we call it
ad
check what do we call it
Edie
so what we might want to do is when the
user clicks on one of those four
operators we want to kind of set inside
of our internal component state what our
operator is going to be when we click
the equal button so up here I'm going to
make a new data called operator and I'll
set it to null for now and basically
whenever we click one of these we're
just going to define the operator as a
new callback function so for each of
these is going to take a and B and it's
going to return some type of math that
is happening between those two so in
this case divided will be this
and then for the other ones we're simply
just going to change what the operator
is doing so this one will be a times B
this one will be a minus B
and this one will be a plus B
so I'll save that and as we click these
things or operator is going to change
depending on the last thing that we
clicked
the last step is how do we actually use
these right basically we can't use it
until we click the equal button
so let's go over here and add a click
callback to equal
and make another function and this will
all make sense when we tie it together
in just a second
so basically when the user types in a
number like 200 we click Add we know
that the operator is going to be set to
the add operator and then when we type a
new number we need to kind of keep track
of that previous and current number so
notice if I were to type a number now
it's just appending to the current so
some additional logic we need to do is
I'm going to say make another one called
previous
which is set to null
then I also want to add a boolean called
operator clicked which is going to be
false
so anytime we click one of these
operators we just basically want to do
operator clicked
is equal to true
and then we want to set the previous
equal to the current
and I could probably abstract this into
a helper
function since is very very similar
logic between all these so let's kind of
do that
honestly set previous is a function we
going to just run those two commands and
I'm going to call
set previous
all these right so
it's not set previous
all right so let's try that now so if we
click on 200 we click plus we click 200
again notice that that is not working
just yet and that is because we forgot
to clear out
current right so basically after we've
clicked operator clicked we need to
check to see if we've clicked an
operator when we call that a pin method
so over here what I can do is just say
if this dot operator clicked is true
we need to say this dot current is equal
to an empty string and then this knot
operator clicked is equal to false to
kind of set it back to that empty state
and of course we can just continuously
get pinned to the current after we set
it equal to empty string
let's try this again we just say one
plus two
notice that previous is one and current
is set to two here now the last step is
when we click equal we want to run that
operator against the previous in the
current
hmm so what I can say is
this current is equal to this dot
operator this dot current and this dot
previous basically take the current
value and run the operator against the
previous value
this is not going to work because this
is a string and this is a string so what
we need to do first is ours that to a
float
and then make sure we cast it to a
string here
hmm so let's try that out and see what
happens in fact we probably want to
reset previous after we've done that but
I'm gonna set that back to null here
so let's try out some of the stuff
so I'll do like one plus two equals
three plus five three equal eight minus
eight should equal zero times five
should equal zero plus 10
five is 50 divided by four is point zero
eight times 100 gives us that negate it
at eight go back to zero let's say 90
let me clear it and go to 90 percent
times 100 should be ten-hour sorry
should be 90
negate that and add 10 to get negative
80 so our calculator is pretty much
working I think there's like a bug or
two like for instance if you do if
you're at zero and do plus or minus
that's kind of like a little bug
and then also like I think normal
calculators as you keep pressing the
operators it's going to like run your
equal but I'm not gonna dive into kind
of fixing those I just wanted to kind of
show you a really quick overview a
building out a calculator app using view
J s honestly you didn't take any time at
all it's pretty straightforward you want
to try to fix those bugs feel free to do
so on my git repo and post a pull
request
but for now I think this is a a good
ending point for this tutorial so if you
have any questions or comments or
concerns feel free to leave some in the
comment section below and if you have
any recommendations of future little
like mini projects that I could try to
build again leave me a comment or send
me a tweet on Twitter well so that about
wraps it up thanks for watching and
happy coding